ja und jetzt haben wir die bilder zu der
meldung die ich vorhin schon
angesprochen habe bilder die einen
historischen moment zeigen man sieht wie
der ukrainische präsident seelen ski
einen eilantrag unterschreibt den
eilantrag mit der bitte zur aufnahme in
die europäische union der ukrainische
präsident hat bereits tage zuvor die
sofortige aufnahme seines landes in die
eu gefordert dies sei nun ein
entscheidender moment die zitat
langjährige diskussion
abzuschließen und bevor wir schwarzen
geben wir zu paul ronzheimer unseren
reporter vor ort in kiew paul ein in der
tat ein historischer antrag wie es paul
wies der wie wir darauf genommen er in
kiew du musst das sind ganz aktuelle
news aber natürlich feiert hier so etwas
das ist erneut ein zeichen wie sehr ihr
präsident so lenz ist schafft trotz
dieses krieges trotz der angriffe aus
russland trotz der eigenen lebensgefahr
seinen weg weiter zu gehen und den weg
vor allem der ukraine weiter zu gehen
thomas das ist etwas historisches 2004
entstanden die menschen mit europäischen
flaggen auf den meiler und haben für
europa für ihre eigenen rechte gegen
janukowitsch demonstriert auch damals
als wladimir putin gesagt das sind alles
nazis dort sind wir russen
die ukraine gehört zu russland und hat
sich gegen diese demonstration gesperrt
und jetzt dieser
unglaublichen situation in der
dramatischen situation eines krieges
unterzeichnet ist ein antrag im landtag
ursula von der leyen die eu
kommissionspräsidenten hat sich ja
bereits offen gezeigt dafür und hat
gesagt die ukraine gehört zu uns manche
werden fragen warum erst jetzt das kann
man immer fragen aber das ist natürlich
eine wahnsinnige symbolik auch immer
sich dieses foto anschaut thomas da
sieht man doch die sandsäcke liegen die
den raum schützen sollen gegenangriffe
also ein antrag auch wirklich in dieser
kriegs atmosphäre so muss man es nennen
das hat es in der geschichte von europa
noch nicht
ronzheimer live aus kiew in diesem jahr
in der tat historischen moment vielen
dank paul